buonasera a tutti eheheh sono
ricercatore del consiglio nazionale
delle ricerche
e lavoro in un istituto d scienze e
tecnologie dei materiali ceramici
compositi che ha sede a faenza
sono venuta qui
con il mio cranio vi prometto che non vi
reciterò
l'amleto di shakespeare
ma ti parlerò di materiali per la
medicina rigenerativa
attività che svolgo con un gruppo di
giovani molto motivati
che fanno parte del mio gruppo e che
vedete qui
le incarti
la medicina rigenerativa per lavorare a
un forte impatto
seu molte delle hackyour gr
pelle in particolare la chirurgia
ortopedica
la neurochirurgia la trilogia
maxillo-facciale dentale
è ormai sotto gli occhi di tutti che lo
stile di vita e invecchiamento della
nostra società
hanno creato un impatto molto negativo
sulle
patologie che riguardano l'apparato
muscolo-scheletrico
in particolare le cause possono essere
di carattere traumatico oh the
generativo come le infezioni croniche le
malattie tumorali
in tutti questi casi
il chirurgo si in sala operatoria si
trova a far fronte
alla mancanza di tessuto
sia che inizi asporti una porzione
per ragioni degenerative operatori
traumatiche
ora il tessuto osseo è uno dei
pochissimi tessuti
eheh del nostro organismo anche in grado
si di riparare una frattura
ma non è in grado di rigenerare anpi e
porzioni di se stesso
porzioni massive
pertanto il chirurgo si trova davanti
all'impossibilità
di far fronte a questa mancanza di
tessuto
se non lo è attraverso l'utilizzo di
impianti ossei
cioè intelaiature tridimensionali
che here noi dobbiamo progettare in modo
tali
in modo tale che le cellule
lun riconoscano aderiscono a questo
impianto
di prolific i know
e rigenerano
per pian piano il tessuto mancante
sia digerendo rimpianto hey rigenerando
lo
o anche lasciando il sito ma il nostro
target e quello di fare scomparire
completamente
l'impianto ostro
e quindi di creare un ponte nuovo
dove era lo spazio
diciamo del tessuto mancante
formato
esattamente identico allo stesso tessuto
osseo mancante
eheh
le problematiche più frequenti è come
abbiamo detto sono relative alle ossa
lunghe per ragioni traumatiche pensate
al numero enorme di incidenti
dovute ahahah deformità dello scheletro
eh sono e diciamo problematiche relative
alle ossa piatte
e' il caso della delle nostre del cranio
oggi
non so se tutti siete a conoscenza del
fatto che per qualunque trauma cranico
di una entità
sopra la valore medio quindi medio alta
il chirurgo
asportano per collo cranico
e non si aspetta un certo tempo
e' necessario per la decompressione dei
ematomi
dell'ematoma del centro e dei centri
nervosi
quindi non si fa più come una volta in
quel paziente veniva tenuto ris
aspettava vedere che cosa succederà che
cosa a che cosa avrebbe portato quel
trauma
sì apre il cranio e si aspetta la
decompressione per evitare
lesione dei centri nervosi
poi questo cranio deve venire chiuso
ma il nostro osso asportato
non è più in grado di chiudere
la la carità aperta
perchè e va incontro un processo di
riassorbimento rapido
per cui
il nostro percolo cadrebbe all'interno
quindi deve essere progettato un
materiale
allo stesso modo
lei e 3 scusate lee è relazione tutte
le problematiche costo cartilagine
helmut dovute alle elezioni
dell'articolazione del ginocchio
dell'anca
rappresenta una potere gh estremamente
pne frequente
negli sportivi
e anche in tutti diciamo in tutta la
popolazione in una fascia d'età molto
ancora barsantini individui molto
giovani
tradizionalmente si interveniva per
sgonfiare a tutte queste problematiche
cercando di risolvere il problema dal
punto di vista funzionale
quindi sono state progettate delle
soluzioni
come vedete qui descritte
placche metalliche gtt grandi protesi
metalliche
nelle acque periodo che va dagli anni
sessanta fino all'inizio degli anni 90
per tutta bella diciamo la progettazione
delle protesi e degli impianti e
dominata
dalla ricerca sulle plastiche
sì materiali metallici
si pensava a riprodurre
funzionalità del paziente carige a
ripristinare la funzionalità del
paziente
non ci si preoccupava di quanto queste
protesi ecco queste placche metalliche
avrebbero
% avuto che che tipo di impatto
avrebbero avuto sull'organismo
c'è un impatto estremamente invasivo
voi immaginate che per introdurre una
protesi di questo tipo il chirurgo deve
asportare
una porzione molto estesa del tessuto
osseo
oltre a quello già mancante
quindi poiché la durata delle protesi
e di un tempo limitato non va oltre i 10
15 anni
se viene protesizzato l'individuo
giovane
questo puoi per dovrà la protesi dovrà
essere
sostituita
il chirurgo si troverà davanti a un
problema doppio di quello iniziale
illa ricercatore che si occupa di
sviluppo di materiale nella medicina
rigenerativa
re ha pensato di prendere ispirazione
dalla natura
ci sono vari modi con cui questi amo
prendere ispirazione dalla natura
per in quanto la naturale pillola un
progettista abilissimo
ha fornito materiali
estremamente
per performanti materiali
multifunzionali capaci di auto
rigenerarsi
e quindi noi possiamo seguire un
approccio
top down e prendere questi materiali
dalla natura come la natura ci
rifornisce
e trasformarli a nostro piacimento
oppure
possiamo copiare dalla natura
con me appunto ingeniere abilissimo
copiare i processi che la natura mette
in atto
produrre sui materiali
un esempio
d hair
approccio
top down è quello che abbiamo
realizzato nei nostri laboratori
dopo una estensiva ricerca
sulle specie arboree
abbiamo identificato il materiale
e che si chiama rattan è un legno che
viene utilizzato per fare sedie da
giardino
potete vedere da questa immagine
l'incredibile similitudine
della ratta anna con il tessuto osseo
mano
dove noi riconosciamo questi canali
centrali camping che sono al centro dell
osteone
questi canali a persiane che trasportano
sata attraverso cui passano
i vasi sanguigni
una serie di strutture
porosa intorno al canale a veneziano che
consente ai fluidi via l'ossigeno di
portare
% diciamo nutrimento le cellule
una struttura lamellare complessa
che da le proprietà
e meccaniche funzionali al tessuto osseo
e queste tutte queste caratteristiche
video struttura gerarchicamente
organizzata dalla mano a lamma toscana
tipiche del tessuto osseo li abbiamo
ritrovate
nella rattan questo legno
abbiamo quindi pensato
d per mettere a punto un processo cioè
di prenderlo dalla natura e di
trasformarlo il processo di
trasformazione
è un processo chimico multi startup che
parte da una piroli
che come fosse un processo di
fossilizzazione come quando si trova
un tronco
antico la dignità e che di milioni di
anni che ha questa
caratteristica di essere stato
trasformato
inna carbone e perché viene trovato
già sotto il terreno e allo stesso modo
noi abbiamo già attuato questo processo
che parte da un film da un processo di
pirrolici
e
otteniamo quindi la trasformazione della
cellulosa in
unina temp lante in una struttura abate
di carbonio
e cambiamo senza mai modificare la
struttura della panna cambiamo alla
chimica intorno a questo atomo di
carbonio
introduciamo il calcio elemento
fondamentale l'ossigeno il carbonato di
fosfato
alla fine abbiamo tenuto
lo stesso rapallo stessa struttura
tridimensionale gerarchicamente
organizzata
con la composizione chimica
dell'idrossido appetite
la fase minerale costituente l'80 % in
peso del tessuto osseo umano
adesso vediamo un filmato che ci mostra
come il nostro adia questa struttura
tridimensionale gerarchicamente
organizzata
molto difficile da riprodurre
il laboratorio
facile da trovare in natura
e quindi avendo la struttura
vedete riprodotta in quest'ora tanto non
possiamo trattare la
chimicamente senza alterare
la morfologia
e la struttura complessa derrata
ne vengono utilizzate aderire
rt formichina alta pressione
e art quello che otteniamo alla fine
appunto da dopo questo trattamento
un cantante
cioè una struttura in carbonio che
mantiene la forma
quell'attimo di carbonio poi viene
trasformato
in idrossiapatite
questi materiali sono già stati
sperimentati sugli animali
gli ultimi animali sono in questo
momento ina s limentazione all ospedale
agli ospedali ortopedici rizzoli di
bologna
e e sono stati impiantati
in un difetto critico sulla pecora
cosa vuol dire critico cioè questo
materiale è stato progettato per per
far fronte alla problematica
di mancanza
d segmenti lunghi per la sostituzione di
ossa lunghe portanti carico che hanno
quindi una struttura
per cui la biomeccanica dell'osso
verrà rispettata durante il processo di
rigenerazione ossea
la vedete ella controllo radiografico
per ora è stato ottimo
e la istologia che vedete riportata qui
fa vedere che il materiale
è stato completamente rigenerato da
tessuto osseo
nuovo
pensate quindi all'impatto quando questo
materiale entrerà nei test clinici
subito dopo la fine dei test animali
passerà alla clinica
l'impatto che potrà avere un materiale
di questo genere che vedete inserita in
un femore della donna che sta correndo
rispetto
a placche metalliche
chiodi
che non verranno mai più tolti nel caso
di
mancanza di un lungo segmento postino
passiamo invece ho un esempio d
approccio
bottom up
dove invece noi prendiamo un processo
che la natura
mette in atto è quello che il processo
di dio mineralizzazione che la natura
acqua all'interno del nostro organismo
per generare il tessuto osseo
il tessuto osseo eccomi ho detto un
tipico esempio di dio mineralizzazione
su un cantante organico che in questo
caso il collagene
quel collagene fa da base
mentre si forma il collagene dalla mano
fibra la macro fibra
in tessuto a formare un tessuto
contemporaneamente avviene la
deposizione di nano nuclei di trost
epatite
danno forza estructura
a questo collagene
abbiamo quindi
tentato di rifare
questo processo in laboratorio e come
vedete ci siamo riusciti abbiamo
prodotto un materiale composito
completamente analogo
al tessuto osso naturale
avendo raggiunto questo target abbiamo
pensato che allora potevamo anche
riprodurre emp delle regioni anatomiche
multifunzionali
come per esempio
la regione poste o cartilaginea
cioè l'articolazione
dove abbiamo collagene mineralizzato che
forma la porzione a ostia la fase
minerale diminuisce gradualmente fino
arrivare alla cartilagine
che altri non è che collageno
quindi abbiamo pensato possiamo produrre
un materiale
a gradiente
con posizionale morfologico e così
abbiamo fatto
abbiamo tentato di riprodurre l'osso
e la cartilagine mineralizzate e quindi
lo strato cartilagineo senza fase
minerale
questa web
alla vostra reading destra
vedette la nostro materiale alla
sinistra una regione osteocondrale
naturale
il materiale
è stato l'ho sperimentato
per sull'uomo già per piede in uno
studio multicentrico in tutti gli
ospedali d'europa
come vedete abbiamo un materiale
tristrato
che mimma l'osso la cartilagine
mineralizzata che la cartilagine
soprastante
in caso di lesioni non troppe spese fino
a un massimo di 4 centimetri quadrati
la missione sia essa osteoartrite
dissecante sia essa una lesione dovuta
trauma sportivo
eliminata
con un intervento
come vedete in questo filmato
e here
melania rea -
eheh presentata in maniera geometrica
cosicché
hillary nostro materiale
con delle semplici forbici chirurgiche
può essere tagliato corrispondentemente
emesso nella visione
le cellule
denicar dovute al sanguinamento che
passano
hair add al sangue subcondrale verso lo
stato cartilagineo saranno in grado
di differenziarsi
i'm tessuto osseo nella parte bassa per
semplice informazione chimica
hey inna struttura cartilaginea
nella parte alta
avremo quindi la completa il completo
ripristino
riad e lira regione costo condrale
e la cura nel tempo nel tempo di circa 3
mesi
la completa ricostruzione dei tessuti
occhio
e cartilagine
la istologia dimostra che c'è completa
rigenerazione
di osso edicart i lati
ovviamente l'impatto che questo
materiale può avere evidente
qui vedete le protesi tradizionali
l'acquisizione di di questo femore
dentro cui deve entrare un infimo lo
metallico di circa 20 centimetri
quindi tutto questo scompare
e abbiamo come vedete nell'immagine
alla vostra destra
unina
materiale molto piccolo
che con me una mosaico plastica già a
sostituire la lesione
e qui vedete l'immagine della lesione
ostia ti cartilaginea completamente
ripristinata
di un paziente senti diciamo
curato qui all ospedale ortopedico
rizzoli
pretty questi materiali è
eheh una ali un album
photo è nato sede staccata dal nostro
gruppo di ricercatori ha creato un
impresa
aika aika nel mondo bio medicale
questa impresa si chiama finceramica
sega a faenza
ed è diventata leader mondiale nella
riparazione del trasimeno
come egli ha spiegato prima per te
occorre progettare materiali per la
ripresa dei cani in tutti i casi in cui
siamo sport asportazione del opercolo
cranico o per trauma proprio della the
happy capranica
e l dal atac del paziente
abbiamo ehm la immagine l'attacca diene
inviata i lavoratori e sulla tattica
viene realizzato il presto il pezzo
mancante grazie a un processo di rapid
prototyping che vedete qui nell'immagine
illa materiale viene riconosciuto come
proprio in quanto
riproduce la morfologia
e la struttura e la composizione
dell'osso kimmich dell'orso umano
quindi le cellule
dalla teca passano all'impianto fiorillo
rigenerano riformando corso autologo
cioè l'osto del paziente
quindi nel giro di un anno
l'impianto sto è scomparso e abbiamo
costo del paziente vedete nell immagine
radiografica la perfetta continuità tra
la protesi e la tecnica
lultima
cosa di cui voglio parlare per larghi è
l' ultima delle innovazioni che abbiamo
realizzato che quella di sostituire
piccole concentrazioni di calcio dei
nostri impianti ossei condivisioni ferro
questo fanno hair
fanno che inducono
un'altra capacità super paramagnetica
nell'impianto ostia che abbiamo
progettato questo vuol dire che
quell'impianto ostia sarà in grado di
rispondere a campi magnetici esterni
anche molto bassi quindi quell'impianto
funzionerà come una stazione in vivo
controllabile dall esterno quindi
opposto aumentare fortemente attivando
l'impianto con dei campi magnetici la
capacità di rigenerazione del mio
impianto dai 6 mesi
posso ridurre
probabilmente in 2 mesi o meno grazie a
un processo di richiamo di attivazione
dei fattori di crescita dei fattori
vascolari non solo
abbiamo già verificato e lo vedete in
questa istologia
che l'ho sto possiamo indurre la
formazione di aosto
lamellare orientato
e quindi aumentare è fortemente le
proprietà biomeccaniche di quel tessuto
candia maris generare e da ultimo forse
un sogno potremmo %
progettare degli impianti hi fi
fattori esterni in maniera pc
e ovviamente
all'utilizzo di viti
chiodi che nella prima fase di
rigenerazione
siamo costretti a mettere per tenere
fermo l'impianto
vi lascio the ring a te vi saluto
vi lascio con questa frase di siena e
kate che pur essendo stata scritta 2000
anni fa e' sicuramente molto attuale nel
mondo della ricerca grazie